it's not every time i make a video
that's terrifying on a level of
something that could actually happen to
you
the viewer usually my videos are in
circumstances of some very unlucky
people
or an event in history that has a low
probability of happening to you
however today i'm talking about primary
amoebic menengio encephalitis
or more simply the brain eating amoeba
what makes this so terrifying is all you
need to get infected
is to mistakenly get water up your nose
that's it
okay so brain-eating amoeba what is it
well
it's not a prokaryote nor a virus the
brain-eating amoeba or negleria phalari
is actually a eukaryote a member of the
same domain as plants and animals
only instead of being multicellular like
plants and animals
enfollery is unicellular a single-celled
eukaryote known
as a protozoan by the way there's over
50 000 different species of protozoans
and fallery is found in aquatic
environments specifically
in warm fresh water such as ponds lakes
hot springs geothermal vents and even
the water from your faucet and shower
head
however it cannot survive in salt water
nor chlorinated water
so your pool and all five oceans of the
world are safe
by the way you know what else is safe
atlas vpn
in addition to encryption and privacy
protection atlas vpn offers unfettered
access to all kinds of tv shows and
movies that are blocked in the united
states
maybe after learning that you could have
your brain effectively eaten by a
protozoan
just by getting water up your nose you
may want to switch gears and watch
something on netflix
ah but netflix doesn't have the movie
that you want to watch
that's because you're geographically
blocked in the united states
atlas vpn allows you to access media
outside your region by changing your
location to another country
if your region doesn't have a specific
movie or tv show you want
you can change to a country that does
this is the lowest price vpn that
effectively protects your privacy
and circumvents streaming service
restrictions and best of all it's not
just netflix
atlas vpn includes amazon prime hbo hulu
disney plus and more so if you want to
seriously upgrade your streaming
experience and get more tv shows and
movie access
click the link in the description now
back to the brain eating amoeba
alright so you get water up your nose
and now you're infected
hold on it's not as simple as that
getting water up your nose is a common
occurrence and yet thousands of people
are not dying from brain eating amoebas
in this case you basically have to snort
or inhale water up your nose
water must reach the cripper form plate
located at the roof of your nasal cavity
where old factory nerves perforate from
your brain however
you can drink water containing enfollery
this is because your stomach acids kill
it so this route is not infectious
and folaray being native to aquatic
environments survives as a flagellate
using its two flagella for swimming
once it's inhaled into the nasal cavity
with water it swims and attaches itself
to olfactory epithelial tissue
on the cribiform plate within a few
hours of attaching it transforms from
its flagellar form into a trophozoite
form where it becomes an amoeba
one of these guys this is where things
get very bad the flagellate form is
mainly for mobility
and is essentially harmless but the
trophozoite form is for feeding
and that's exactly what it does to your
nervous system and followery consumes
olfactory nerve fibers in your nasal
cavity that lead a short distance to
your brain
devouring nerves and multiplying as it
moves deeper into your cranial cavity
the amoeba consumes cells by first
facultizing or engulfing them
and then injecting destructive enzymes
into the cytoplasm
breaking down the cell and its internal
components so it can be digested
once and followery reaches the brain
catastrophic effects begin to manifest
it consumes neurons that send nerve
signals throughout the body thereby
compromising bodily functions instead of
just one
isolated area this is where the
infection becomes fatal
the initial destruction of nerve cells
in the nasal cavity was bad but
not fatal it only affected olfactory
nerves and resulted in minor effects
such as fever loss of smell nasal
inflammation and pain in the immediate
area
after several days of multiplying
consuming neurons and causing
inflammation
cells in the brain start to become
necrotic and release a wave of toxic
enzymes which creates a positive
feedback loop of inflammatory responses
and more necrosis thereby exacerbating
the destruction
widespread nerve damage causes impartial
nerve signaling resulting in cognitive
decline
tremors seizure high fever and
inflammation of the brain and meninges
which is notably painful inflammation of
the brain is the last and most severe
stage of the infection
inflammation causes the brain to expand
and fluid builds up in the cranial
cavity
the pressure of the brain expanding and
the pressure from the fluid buildup puts
an immense amount of force on the brain
itself
however the survival of the individual
does not come down to the brain
but rather the brain stem the brain
itself is pretty resilient
in my other video can you survive a
headshot there's numerous people who
survive gunshots directly to the head
think about how many people get severe
concussions and still live
now the brain stem on the other hand is
incredibly fragile
it controls your breathing and heart
rate so any damage to it
is always fatal eventually the patient
succumbs due to a very high pressure in
the skull that damages the brain stem
and once that happens
it's over from the date of infection to
death
is about 12 days less than 2 weeks
what makes this infection so terrifying
aside from the short window of survival
is the fact that it has very few
successful treatments this is due to the
fact that it's difficult to diagnose
and by the time it is diagnosed it's too
late as the damage in the brain has
become fatal this is why the infection
has a 98.5 percent fatality rate
in the united states there have been 148
known cases of then following infections
from 1962-2019
however this number is likely higher as
is difficult to diagnose
as the infection mimics both bacterial
and viral meningitis
of the 148 people who contracted
enfollary infections
only four survived recently as of 2010
data has been collected on the
transmission of end follower
infections since 2010 there have been 34
deaths from end follower
infections 88 were infected by way of
recreational water
most likely in a fresh water pond or
small lake where hot weather makes the
water warmer thereby increasing the
number of anthology protozoans
8.8 were infected by use of a neti pot
and 3.3 through the unfortunate use of a
slip n slide
which makes sense as water can forcibly
go up your nose
and is not chlorinated but rather from a
garden hose
now if you're terrified of swimming
taking a shower or using a neti pot calm
down
and take a breath there are very
specific circumstances that must be met
to cause an
infection firstly the water pretty much
has to be either inhaled or forcefully
sprayed up your nose
this is pretty hard to do in the shower
and as far as swimming goes
just use your pool it's chlorinated so
it's safe avoid swimming in ponds hot
springs rivers or
lakes secondly when using a neti pot
don't use water from the tap
and fallery can live in tap water
because they can tolerate higher
temperatures than most microorganisms
and can survive dormant as a cyst for
long periods of time without food
instead of tap water just use bottled
distilled water and sterilize your neti
pot